sergeant you were in the 1:8 with me
though you were significantly fatter sir
they called me Terry titties because I
had large titties yes I remember I never
liked that nickname though to be fair it
was accurate what's this I hear about
you being on administrative leave
a year ago my wife and I had twin baby
girls Cagney and Lacey
they have adorable chubby cheeks ever
since I kind of got scared of getting
hurt lost my edge there was an incident
in a department store
Oh fine I think he's dead and I'm still
not right tell me about the detective
squad um well Scully Hitchcock and
Daniel's they're pretty much worthless
but they make good coffee
cut that not a good ones rose the DEA's
tough smart hard to read and really
scary tell me who has me for Secret
Santa Oh
all the fun out of it it's Scully
you got your scarf I'll make him return
it yes you will
Charles Boyle he's a grinder not the
most brilliant detective but he works
harder than anyone else he's not
physically gifted oh man my muffin oh my
head I'm up in my head he stepped on him
on my muffin on my head on my muffin Amy
Santiago she's got seven brothers so
she's always trying to prove she's tough
careful that stuff's pretty hot oh is it
she and Peralta have some big bet over
who gets more arrests this year ever
since the bet the numbers have gone way
up don't be about Peralta Jacob Peralta
is my best detective he likes putting
away bad guys and he loves solving
puzzles the only puzzle he hasn't saw is
how to grow up that was very well put
I've talked about about Jake in mind
apparently mandated
you